we you basically do quantitative and
qualitative research in order to
understand how people think
[Music]
italian wolf thank you so much for
joining 20 minute leaders good morning
good morning thank you so much for
having me chief
optimizer at get uplift what does it
mean
to be an optimizer
well we help uh brands high growth
brands optimize their funnels and their
websites so essentially
turning more of their traffic into
customers
leads users and so on so the idea is
to leave the traffic as is and basically
optimize the website
whether if it's the copy the user
experience the journey itself the
visuals
and so on and run a b tests in order to
see
what actually increases conversions so
it sounds exciting conversions are
incredibly challenging and i'm excited
to learn more about
about the space about the challenges
about the creative solutions around it
but even more exciting than that is is
jumping from a plane so talia how do you
get to do a thousand
a thousand jumps from an airplane how
does that happen
you have to be crazy no um i don't know
i
i went to see some i went a friend i
went to see a friend of mine
jumping out of a plane she was doing a
course i saw it
and i was like okay yeah this seems cool
and that was basically
it um yeah i've
i've skydived actually i've skydived a
lot in the us
too so um in the area of california
quite a bit and where else chicago
but why do a course i mean i you know i
i skydived
twice or three times and and you know
it's an exhilarating journey
it's a i i almost peed my pants every
time and i and i keep asking myself why
did i do this to myself
and but but then i i i'm always happy
that i did
but what motivates you to go and do a
real course and be certified in that
you know what it's probably the most
amazing feeling you can ever get and the
best feeling for me is that moment when
you leave
the plane it's not even the fall itself
when we're doing all these elaborate
cool things or if the
or you know flying a canopy it's
actually that moment
when you are leaving the plane and
what's cool about it is
that your i mean for me at least my
brain's working 24 hours so i'm
constantly
thinking and working and constantly
thinking about things
and when you jump out of a plane there
is pure
two minutes of nothing and it's not just
nothing like a void it's nothing it's
filled with
calm it's just amazing and of course
there's the adrenaline and all the fun
and jumping with friends and and
competitions and all that but
the calm the i'm not thinking about
anything right now
talia do you understand this moment do
you understand the absurdity of
how you're describing that calm feeling
of jumping out of an airplane
falling at an acceleration of 10 meters
per second
and you're saying but it's the calm it's
two minutes of calmness
it's so who every anybody that's
listening to this that hasn't jumped off
of a plane i mean i can testify somewhat
i think you're being completely
delusional that it's that it's a calm
experience and i
scream my heart out the whole time but
but i'm sure that uh you know
hopefully i'll get to that point one day
i'll i'll pro i'll meditate here on the
couch in the meantime
uh but thank you talia why
why is the conversion so hard
what is and what is conversion first of
all to whoever doesn't necessarily
really grasp it
all right so essentially when you start
a business whether
if it's an e-commerce business or maybe
it's a sas product
you're trying to get conversions you're
trying to get more sales maybe even
if you're a consultant you're trying to
get leads if you're
a sas company then you're trying to get
users and people to sign up for a free
trial or schedule a demo
those aren't conversions it's what your
company decides on
and you're driving traffic you're
spending a ton of money in
ads on google on facebook or doing seo
or content writing in order to drive as
many people as possible to
your website or to your landing pages in
order to convert
people into leads or into uh
sign ups and so on and the thing is that
for many many years
most companies spent a lot of money on
driving that traffic to the website but
didn't think about what happens when
people
actually arrive on the website right how
do you convince people
to sign up and what's really interesting
is that
these days we live in a world where we
see
40 000 messages a day i mean everyone's
targeting us
everyone's trying to get us get our
attention so how do you actually
stand out in that crowd and get your
prospect to say
yes this company looks interesting and
i'm not gonna go and look at the five
other comp
competitors and that's conversion
optimization it's about
optimizing the experience that people go
through when they get to your website
and funnel so that you can get more
conversions and so what are the main
attributes that that would
make me as a consumer first of all
before we even talk about the marketing
and me as a consumer what are some of
the main rationalizations that i go
through
or what is the behavior that i exhibit
as i'm being targeted
that would maybe enforce me to go in one
direction or another because i think
that that is the foundation of the
of this whole issue right what how what
motivates me i i worked with dana really
quite a bit
with irrational labs and so thinking
about consumer behavior has been
a lifelong passion but but i'm excited
to hear your take on
from a conversion standpoint this is a
hundred percent
so most times when you think about
optimizing for conversion people think
okay
i'll make button bigger or i'll change
the headline and that's going to work
but actually the process that we've
developed the methodology that i
developed
is called emotional targeting and it's
exactly based on everything that dan
really does it's all about understanding
how people make decisions
when you understand how people make
decisions their
real intent the different psychological
triggers and biases that we have in our
brain
it's easier for you to understand what
kind of experience someone needs to go
through in order to convert
it's never going to be the same but you
have different target audiences
that act in different ways so if you can
understand the pains the challenges
the different roadblocks that people are
going through and most importantly
the desired outcome what is that
emotional
feeling that people are looking for and
i'll give you an example please uh
you're not buying a t-shirt
you're buying self-esteem you're not
buying
um insurance
you're you're not basically you're not
buying a piece of paper for insurance
you're buying uh security you're buying
peace of mind
and that is that is basically the the
difference between just changing an
element
on the page and hoping that it will get
more signups
versus actually thinking about what is
that emotional
drive what is the emotional uh intent
behind a decision and then creating an
experience for that
so it's it's it just requires a lot of
research and understanding intent and
how people make decisions just like you
mentioned
right how do you get started even
researching this so becoming
somewhat of an expert in in this idea of
rational because the these
these analogies that you just made
you're not buying a t-shirt you're
buying self-esteem you're not buying and
you're not buying insurance as a piece
of paper you're buying
comfort and peace of mind it tells it's
a process not you know it's not like the
average person can just come and say
okay
i i'm understanding how how people think
how do you get started with that
yeah well it's funny because when i
started out with conversion optimization
i tried the other thing i tried
reading blog posts and following best
practices and asking people for their
opinion
and that tanked like literally i lost a
hundred thousand dollar client because
of that really so
wow well that's how you know when you
when you get started you try different
things and you fail and that's great
that's the
life of an entrepreneur um but thanks to
those
fails and to trying these things in that
treadmill just kind of
it's not even a treadmill it's a hamster
wheel you keep going over and over
trying the same things that don't work
so what i did is i basically started
researching how people make decisions in
life
and i understood that what was missing
was that psychology part of it
so you can't just wake up and say oh
okay i know how people think
you have to do method methodological
research
so we do surveys and we use heat maps
and we do
interviews and we use eye tracking and
we use data from google analytics and
we you basically do quantitative and
qualitative research
in order to understand how people think
now what's good and what's on my side is
a b
testing because i can come and say i
think that the emotional drivers
are social um let's say
uh it's social image i want social image
as a psychological trigger which
basically means that we want
uh we care about what other people think
about us on the other side you could
have self-image which is i want to feel
better about myself but let's say
that we've chosen social image that's
what we want to test
so i'll create a variation that focuses
on social image on the
outcome that is social image and how
other people will feel
about you and you test it and you see
the data that comes
in and you see if it works and if it
doesn't and even if it doesn't you've
still learned something
so it's really just about research and
testing all the time
that that makes a lot of sense so talk
walk me through you know the process
you're you're getting a new client and
you're starting to work and obviously i
think one of one of the impressive
things here is that you have to context
switch all the time between different
types of clients right one time it's a
social image another time it's it's
different
it's it's a different trigger or or
cognitive bias that you're trying to
invoke
and so what is the process that you and
your team have to go through in order to
you know first of all optimize yourself
towards that
problem and then the process with that
company of actually finding a solution
that satisfies
yeah that's a great question because
there's also biases that we live in
right even when we go to analyze things
we have our own biases and the things
that we think are going to work
um one of the things that we do is when
we start working with the new client is
we split the work between
different people in the teams um so for
example
if we do an audit on a website then a
lot of it
includes running surveys interviews
something called something called review
mining competitor analysis swat
all that stuff but we get different
people doing it and then we compare our
notes and see if we reach the same
conclusions or
or similar conclusions so it's a process
that really begins with people
and ends with people um and i can tell
you that
with various companies and clients that
we've worked with
we've found that many times without
talking to each other throughout the
process
we'd each come with our own conclusions
that turn out to be very similar
and if they're not then we'll propose
two different tests
so it's a very cool way to go about
the research and to say okay here's what
we're looking here's what we're seeing
on the website we're also using uh
qualitative sorry
quantitative data so we know what's
going on we know how people
are behaving on the website now we have
to basically attach the psychological
part to it so it's research and testing
all the time
sure and and how early do you usually
work with the companies are they
are do they are these companies that are
already you know huge and they have
thousands of potential customers or are
these
also startups that are just trying to
get their product market fit and
understanding
what is the product that we should be
aiming for given a target audience that
we believe in
yeah so for our client work we usually
work with companies that have a minimum
of
300 conversions a month and we do that
because in order to run
a viable test as a statistically
significant test
we need to have about 150 uh conversions
per variation
so that is the best fit so it's usually
more high growth companies
however we do have courses and when we
do the courses and the trainings they
are for uh more of the entrepreneurs and
startups that are just getting started
and want to learn how to do these things
themselves
so they can set themselves up for
success and then later hopefully when
they get to that stage they can always
hire us in order to take them to the
next level right and that makes a lot of
sense so what are some
things that early stage companies young
entrepreneurs can already do as they're
building their product as they're
gaining conversions
in order to get into this conversion
optimization mindset
because obviously it's it's great to be
able to come in and and have
you know get uplift come and and help
when you're at hyper growth but it
sounds to me like this is
almost like a strategy or or a a talent
that you want to improve on
on every step of the journey as the as
the leader in the company
a hundred percent you know what's really
cool
is that being that small startup that
just getting started
even if it's in a very crowded industry
gives you
a lot of advantage um and the advantage
is
that you are leaner and you can move
fast and you can do your research which
a lot of companies now that are huge and
are very big and very well known don't
have the capacity or time to do or even
the people
to do it and even if they did imply
start doing it it would take them
a whole year you as a startup or a
founder can already start
running those those researchers in terms
of
surveying your your potential customers
doing interviews doing the jobs to be
done framework google that it's a super
important
uh framework to do you could be uh
interviewing people you could be doing
review mining
you can really go deep and what's really
cool about this process is that you end
up filing
finding your unique selling proposition
and that unique selling proposition is
gonna help you actually stand out
in front of all those competitors and
big um
the big companies in the industry so you
can get started
immediately by going back to basics and
before you start planning
any landing page any ad or even your
website
first do the research in order to
understand who your customer is
what their desired outcomes are what are
their pains and concerns and make sure
that everything that you create is about
the customer
it's about them and their desired
outcome right i was actually introduced
to
a getting the job that needs to be done
uh
back at a venture capital class at
stanford but i would love for you to
tell us a little bit about about this
concept
and about this this mentality as as a
founder or an entrepreneur
thinking about what is the job that
needs to be done with a customer at the
forefront
what is that framework yeah i mean at
the end of the day what you're trying to
figure out is what is the job that your
prospect is trying to get done with your
uh solution right um and i think that
many times people think
oh you know if they're using a let's say
they're using slack
they're trying to get work done or
trello they're trying to manage their
projects but it's
rarely that simple it's not that they're
trying to manage a project it's that
they're trying to maybe
save time maybe reduce friction within
the company
maybe they're trying to essentially what
they're doing is they're trying to get
to an end result
that is the desired outcome i keep
talking about the easiest way to explain
this
is that if you are a parent and you are
now thinking about
uh buying a product for your child so
maybe it's a toy
maybe it's something that they need to
build
or maybe you're planning a birthday
party for your child
there's a lot of things that come into
place here it's not just about
the act of here i now have plates for
the party or i now have a toy to give to
this kid
it's more about that desired outcome and
what's going to happen at the end
my kid is going to be happy or other
parents are going to know that i am a
great parent or i'm going to feel great
about my parenting skills
so it's always about that job that
people are trying to get done and
there's a cool framework that really
helps you
what's good about this specific
framework is just that it takes you away
from the personas
which is 90 made up
um and then it takes you into a real
way to framework and understand who
exactly is your customer
what are they trying to get done and how
you should be speaking to them
right no no that makes a lot of sense uh
talia why are you so excited about this
why are you so excited about conversion
optimization
uh obviously i think it's an
exhilarating journey seeing
every you know every day a different
client or every few weeks a different
client and
and solving a different problem and
seeing that that impact
but what is but what is the where's that
passion come from
it's funny that you asked us because i
used to run
a conversion optimization agency and we
sold the agency and i joined a startup
company and i worked
in the startup company as a cmo for
about i don't know eight months and the
whole eight months all i wanted to do
was conversion optimization
and i ended up leaving that company and
going back to starting my own
consulting business for conversion
optimization so i think
first of all i found my passion and i
really do
love what i do i love trying to
understand people and how they make
decisions
and most of all i love helping my
clients i just
really enjoy it and going on that
journey with them
so i'm just really passionate about
about
what i do yeah and how much of that
would you say of your time you spend on
the on the psychological side versus the
the quantitative side that you're
getting and when i say the quantitative
i mean
the google analytics and the a b testing
with the landing pages and the messaging
versus sitting down and saying okay like
let's figure out what is this cognitive
bias that we're invoking
what are the emotions that our user is
experiencing you probably also
encourage doing a lot of you know user
interviews and customer interviews to
understand them but but which which part
do you spend more time on usually
um it depends mostly what happens is
we always start with quantitative so
we'll start with google analytics and
heat maps
in order to understand where the problem
is and what needs mixing and then we'll
use qualitative data in order to answer
how to fix that so google analytics is a
great tool to use in order to understand
like
hey there's a problem on this page or
there's a problem in this funnel but it
doesn't tell you
why that problem is happening so then
we'll use qualitative data in order to
answer that question and figure out okay
so we know there's a problem on the
pricing page or we know there's a
problem in checkout or we know there's a
problem on the home page
how do we fix that what is the problem
in identifying it and then
solving it so most of the time the
biggest part
is the qualitative research because it
takes more time
and it's about solving a problem um
the quantitative is more of an a way of
informing ourselves and understanding
what needs to be fixed right now that
makes a lot of sense by the way do you
have any interesting
case study or or any specific occurrence
with an insight as to
something that surprised you along the
journey that you were working with the
client
you were trying to to focus to solve
some something without with conversion
and
and then you realized that it was
something like really weird or obscure
that
without that research not necessarily
fine
you know um one of my recent uh
tests i worked with uh social media
marketing examiner social oh my god
social media examiner the
they've got the social media examiner
which is the blog and the social media
marketing world which is their
conference
right so sme which is social media
examiner
one of the biggest blogs in the world
for uh social media
they hired us in order to help them sell
more tickets for their conference in san
diego
um and when i looked at their landing
page it wasn't actually
a a classic landing page it's a blog
post
it's essentially a 5000 word blog post
wow and i was looking at it and i kept
thinking
we need to optimize this we need a
classic landing page we need to
you know have a header have this have
real call to action buttons and
and and in the end when we did our
research we realized that the
actual people who are uh coming to this
page
don't need that at all what they
actually need is to have
this specific blog and what we did which
was funny
is that after doing this research we
understood that what was missing was
even more content so we added a whole
section about the pains that they're
going through
all the stuff that isn't working for
them the pains the roadblocks their
challenges
and basically painted the new picture
that could be
and we actually by just adding more copy
to the website
to that page we actually got a fifteen
percent increase in sales
so it's really cool to see that it's not
it's not always the stuff that you think
it's gonna be in the stuff that's most
like uh what everyone else is doing
because any other conference you look at
have a really
cool classic looking landing page and
this is very different
so that's fascinating talia thank you so
much for coming and for
inspiring me these 20 minutes before we
leave i have to ask you the hardest and
most important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
um okay i'm gonna say passionate because
you can hear how yeah
um i'm gonna say dedicated
and i am going to say geek
i love that the third one passionate
dedicated and geek talia thank you very
very much this was wonderful stay safe
and stay healthy
same to you thank you for having me
you